pepper answers with a resounding no in
his book an active state
twenty years after james earl ray was
convicted mr pepper sets out to clear
him detailing a case that accuses the
fbi the cia the us military the memphis
police and local and national organized
crime leaders
this talk from the current affairs
bookstore in san diego is an hour 10
minutes
our speaker this evening is an english
barrister and an american lawyer who
practices international human rights law
from london
he has represented government and heads
of states and appears as an expert on
international law issues
a close friend of dr martin luther king
he also remains to this day a close
friend of the king family
he convenes a seminar on international
human rights in oxford england
so here this evening to talk about his
book
an act of state the execution of martin
luther king we're very pleased to
introduce mr william pepper
[Applause]
good evening
thank you for coming and tearing
yourselves away from the state of the
union address
[Laughter]
so much deja vu
let me try to set the tone
this
all of this work of mine started really
with vietnam
and martin
king's
relationship and association with me
during the last year of his life
was triggered by vietnam and and we try
to just set the tone for
the passion that he felt about that war
because it's i think very appropriate
today there was um
there was a a a poem that moved him
uh
uh very much and very deeply and some of
you may know it it starts off uh i come
and stand at every door
but no one hears my silent tread i knock
and yet remain unseen for i am dead
i am dead
i was only seven when i died in
hiroshima long ago when children
die
i was seven then as i am now when
children die they do not grow
my hair was scorched by swirling flame
my eyes grew dim my eyes grew blind
death came and turned my bones to dust
and i was scattered by the wind
all that i ask is but for peace
you fight today
you fight today
so that the children of this world may
live and grow and laugh and play
now when i came back i was a freelance
journalist
i was really as a kid in in vietnam
and i came back um
never published anything when i was
there
i had to leave because of where i chose
to spend my time when i was in that
country and became
a bit of a
security risk in some ways i suppose
and um
a pace a piece
called the children of vietnam
was included in a magazine called
ramparts which some of you may recall
was old
progressive
ramparts magazine that was published by
warren hinkle up in san francisco
on january 1967 it came out
and
during that month martin king was on his
way to um
the west indies and he was sitting at
the airport in atlanta
with bernard lee his his bodyguard and
going through his mail and in that mail
was a copy of ramparts magazine
and his
his food was waiting to be eaten in
front of him and he started scanning
through the magazine
and it was was the photographs that
stopped him i took
many photographs when i was when i was
there
of uh burned children and shrapnelized
civilians particularly women
and
when he saw the photographs bernard said
he pushed his food away and said
i gave a big sigh and pronounced what's
wrong martin the food is no no good
you're not hungry and he said i can
never be hungry again he said i just
can't bernard until i do something about
this war this war must end
he had of course been opposing it
instinctively for a long time
but
he now consolidated that opposition he
asked to meet with me and for the
for the
times early times that we met he asked
to see other photographs files notes i'd
taken and i shared them with him and i
remember on the way to um to cambridge
from providence rhode island where he
delivered a sermon
and brown chapel we wrote to cambridge
where vietnam summer was going to be
open that was one of the anti-war
movements
organizations up at harvard
and i was going through material with
him in the car in the way and he
it was too much he just openly wept
and i had become
heartened by it because i had i had been
amongst it for a period of time and i
and uh
but to him
he never
he never could accept that and he became
very emotional about this thing
so then he delivered his speech
on
the
4th of april
1967 at riverside church
and before he did that
he said to me he said to me bill will
you come down to ebenezer and will you
take the pulpit and will you speak to my
people
i thought he'd gone round to bed and i
said what
what do you do you want a hunky from the
north to come down
talk to your people he says yes you must
come down and talk to them i said why
this is silly they're your people martin
you talk to them you've always talked to
them
and he waved his finger never forget he
waved his finger in front of us he says
no he said no
you've been there
you've seen it
you must tell them
what i have to do
and they'll listen to you
and that
brought
a loss of words to me and i so i went to
ebenezer and spoke to them and explained
why
i respectfully thought
their pastor had to oppose this war
which he then did
and
the last year of his life that was the
only year that i knew him we worked
closely together because
he was willing to take every uh
opportunity to
to organize and to encourage the end of
the war so it was it was planned to have
a national conference for new politics
was an umbrella organization he asked me
to lead it
and become its director
and
it was to bring together from all over
the country people
who were committed to peace and justice
it was a grassroots movement but it
stretched across the socio-economic
range of american society there were 5
000 delegates that eventually came to
the palmer house in chicago on labor day
1967 and the goal was
politically to produce a king spock
ticket as an alternative to the johnson
um
administration's reelection
and
we were so naive
in those days
martin keynoted
the convention
and as he was speaking a note was passed
to me
and i looked at this note
and it said
get him out of here as soon as he
finishes speaking or we will take him
hostage and humiliate him before the
world
that note came from a black caucus
which had been formed
and
put together before the convention but
greeted each
uh member of the black community in
black delegations that came in and took
them into a separate headquarters in a
separate room
and so there was a tight
unified black caucus and that note came
from the black caucus
we didn't know at the time of course
that the black that black caucus had
been uh
consisted of the leadership of jean
provocateur who
were
in the pay of the government of the
united states and in the poverty program
at richard daley in chicago and included
members of the blackstone rangers
gangs in chicago
and that the whole
idea was to come to this convention and
break it up
and defeat it and so what they what they
did
was to introduce
the most
extreme resolutions
possible
and
it had the effect of driving away all
the funding
for that new politics movement
so
it was basically over before it began
that that great political movement and
uh and was fragmented although it limped
along for the course of the year
but as a political movement it ended
now when martin was
killed on april 4 1968
i went to the memorial
with ben spock and i went together to
the memorial and then to the
uh
funeral funeral service in atlanta
and ben and julian bond and some others
i think went up to bobby kennedy's suite
and when bobby had and invited me to to
come up because he of course had
declared for the presidency
uh and was even
flirting with the idea that martin king
might be a running mate for him
um i didn't go to bobby kennedy's suite
i'd known him some years earlier when i
was an even younger person
and i am
and didn't like him
i actually handled a
campaign of his i was his citizens
chairman uh in
one of uh new york state's counties
and um i regret i didn't go now because
bob kennedy between 1964 and 68 i think
was a very different person
i think he grew in enormous ways so i
couldn't um
i had had it
with with political activity in life and
so i just walked away
um
did a number of other things
ten years later
ralph abernathy
said uh to me
out of the blue i want to go and see
james ill ray i want you to interrogate
him and i want to watch him and listen
to his answers because i have some
questions about
james ilray's
guilt i said ralph it's 10 years later
do you ha why do you have these
questions now and
and uh what what has developed i never
got a satisfactory answer for that just
do it for me will you build so
i don't think about the case i said i
know i had assumed they always had the
right man
and never gave it a second thought
as you know and just turned my back and
then but if something if you or hosea
needed you know an extra body at a
demonstration or a march or something
i'm happy it was happy to to come along
and help but
uh
that was the extent of it took several
months for me to get it caught up to
speed on
um
the information about the case and the
history of it and the facts and i did a
lot of reef so we did go
five six months later it was in august
78. imagine that august 1978 first time
i saw james earl ray
ralph abernathy and
a body language specialist from harvard
was a psychiatrist who sat in the corner
and just watched james's every move as i
put him through
a rather rigorous interrogation and of
course his lawyer
at that time was mark lane and mark was
president sat off to the side didn't
interfere at all
well we came away from that five-hour
uh session
uh abernathy and i with a distinct
belief that this man was not the shooter
we didn't know what other role he might
have played in the killing and we didn't
know how
what his what
whether he was uh
he whether he was used as a patsy or
whether he was a willing uh conspirator
who didn't didn't have a sense of that
but we had the feeling distinctly he was
not the shooter it came from
it was visceral but it also was factual
and
he was very different you know he was
very different from the man we had read
about and we had heard about
uh he was not aggressive he was not
brutish he wasn't uh didn't have didn't
appear to have any traces of overt
racism
uh in fact he was docile
he was quiet
spoken he was
even shy very different kind of person
than we had expected
but he raised so many uh questions in my
mind
about
the official story and his own guilty
plea um
scenario
that i decided i would start to look
into this
and see what was possible
find out what i could so i started going
into memphis from time to time
and
hanging out in
south main street in the area of the
lorraine motel
and going over into the black sections
of
south memphis and talking to witnesses
meeting people
and trying to get a sense
of of the answers to questions that had
not been properly asked or answered
and the whole range of them
uh the whole issue of the bushes behind
jim's grill where martin
jim's grill was a cafe that backed onto
the mulberry street and the rain motel
was there
right behind it and supposedly bushes
were cut down in the morning afterwards
why were those bushes cut down and
the whole series a whole series of
questions about that like like that that
that derose so
i started this investigation and it
became a slippery slope
because the deeper i got into it the
more
uh questions i found and i couldn't
answer so i kept going and going
and
i kept going back to see uh to see james
or ray and i kept asking him to clarify
to to
to uh answer
new issues that that i had found
questions and james tried always the
best of his ability he kept asking me to
represent him
well i refused to do that for 10 years
between 78 and 88 i refuse to represent
james because i said to him very frankly
until i'm convinced that you
were
totally an unknowing patsy and not a
knowing conspirator i'm not going to
um
uh represent you
logistically i had problems doing this
time because i was living in england i
was at cambridge living in cambridge for
20
20 years i had gone to england and so i
had to keep coming back and forth i i
raised three children at cambridge and
uh
now then they were very tiny which was
actually one of the reasons i left but
we um
i i made this trip
over a period of the ten years and
finally got enough information to
convince myself
that this man
was an unknowing patsy that he had been
used he'd manipulated and controlled
he'd been set up
uh and
so finally 1988 i agreed to represent
james o'reilly
and i represented him for the last 10
years of his life
he died in prison in 1998
and we tried to get him at trial
um for
all of the period of time and failed
took his case to the supreme court
uh and we we finally
were turned down there only three years
after i came on to represent him
and then the idea of a television trial
came up and so in 1992
thames television in england
and hbo here in the united states
sponsored a trial the trial of james
earl ray
and
the judge was marvin frankel
old tough old former federal judge
prosecutor was hickman ewing jr
name may ring a bell with you because he
was ken starr's number two for a period
of time on the whitewater investigation
and he's a former u.s attorney
so hickman prosecuted i defended uh and
we went at it strictly under
tennessee
criminal code
adhering strictly to that code
um
jury came from all over the country so
it wasn't a local jury
they and we screened them we went
through the usual exclusion
process
took the jury
seven hours after ten days of trial took
them seven hours to find james earl ray
not guilty
with a fraction of the evidence that
was to emerge over the last 10 years
so
probably never heard about that a few of
you may have heard about it
because it was never reported it was
never covered the media uh never
treated it in any way at all as a news
story it was regarded as entertainment
and even then it was not it was not
covered and this has been the history
of this case and it's in the
investigation and the results is that
there is an embargo in the united states
with respect to this story
the book the first book written in 1995
orders to kill was never reviewed in
america
this book will not be reviewed in
america
so when it comes to those kinds of
national security issues very sensitive
issues it's very difficult to get the
story out in the mainstream
after the trial the television trial
witnesses started to come forward
pieces other pieces started to be put in
place
um
a man called lloyd jowers was suddenly
cast into the frame he was the manager
of jim's grill i had found four
witnesses finally
independently
who implicated jowers in the killing of
martin luther king
jowers knew about this
and decided
he was going to be indicted
and asked his lawyer to go and get him
immunity from prosecution and he would
then tell everything
so his lawyer goes trotting over to the
district attorney general's office and
says
you know i represent mr lloyd jowers and
uh he was very much involved in the
assassination of martin luther king but
he knows everything that happened around
his premises where it was planned and
who was involved locally and he's
prepared to give you all that
information
but all he needs is immunity
well not only did jauers not get
immunity from prosecution but he uh was
never interviewed
by the
district attorney general
jairus was still frightened so he tried
to push the envelope a little bit
and
um he
was able to appear on an abc program
called primetime live it's
run by a fellow called sam donaldson who
is a peculiarly independent guy
in terms of that program
jowers told his story about how he was
approached
by a local produce man named frank
liberto who was a member of the marcelo
family marcelo family organization he
worked for them he was one of one of
their one of their guys their
lieutenants in memphis
and
liberto uh offered him a hundred
thousand dollars
and um called in a big do bill he had a
big debt i later found out what that
debt was
and um in exchange for that jowers was
going to do everything he was told and
he was going to allow his facilities to
be used for the planning the staging of
the assassination of martin luther king
and jowers agreed and he went along with
it
and i cover his his whole role and
eventually of course lloyd jarvis has
told everything
uh to dexter king and myself
to andrew young and dexter king
separately
um and he admitted uh the
the scope of his involvement in this
conspiracy
so
we now had the marcello organization
pretty clearly in the frame
and it was looking like a contract
killing
contract killing
carried out by a memphis police
department officer who was paid
to do it
so
we moved beyond jowers to reach out to
other witnesses who came forward
and one of them
told us about living in houston texas
and knowing a fellow called raoul
and becoming friendly with raul and his
cousin armando and going to the docks in
houston
and taking
boxes of weapons and helping transport
them to a house where they were
repackaged and apparently sent into
south america
for
a profit-making operation and she didn't
know where the weapons came from or
anything but she knew about this
operation
and she told a horror story one time she
said she was at the house where she was
uh
unloading these weapons and she put her
key chain on the on the
kitchen table where they were around
where they they were sitting and one of
the guys picked it up and looked at it
and had the photographs in the
little plastic circle of john kennedy
robert kennedy and martin luther king
and he looked at this and he threw it to
raul raul grabbed it looked at it and
became she said totally and furious
threw it on the floor jumped up stamped
on it and said that i killed that [ __ ]
once looks as though i'm going to have
to do it again pulled out a gun
and grabbed glenda who had known this
man
for quite a period of time and took her
into a
bedroom off the kitchen and raped her
and she was
totally uh uh frightened appalled and
didn't know what this was all about
but it obviously led her to believe
quite clearly that this man had some
involvement in the killing of martin
king and she set this whole story out
she didn't tell anybody about this for
many years
you have to understand one of
the reasons that this case has now come
to the point where it's effectively
solved
is that
somehow
people have become willing to come
forward after many years and talk the
first witness to implicate lloyd jowers
betty spades
knew what happened in 1968
and didn't tell it to me until 1992
and i had known betty since 1978
though lloyd had tried to keep me away
from her which made me more and more
suspicious but what actually happened
with betty was
she had an affair with lloyd
and she had tried to keep an eye on him
and she thought that thursday afternoon
that when he wasn't in the grill that
maybe he was out fooling around in the
bushes with one of the uh the the uh the
ladies of the night who used to hang out
there uh around the motel because the
motel in those days was also
we call a hot sheet place i suppose was
used for uh for those kinds of uh dally
answers so she said
well i didn't see him so i decided i was
going to go look
and and find him and and she found the
door to the kitchen closed which was
unusual
and then she found the back door open
which was uh also unusual and as she got
to the back door and started to look out
just before she looked out she heard a
shot
and then as she looked out she saw lloyd
coming running straight from the bushes
toward her carrying a still-smoking
rifle
he brushed past her came inside broke it
down
as he broke it down he looked at her and
he said you wouldn't ever do anything to
hurt me would you
and she says no lord you know of course
i wouldn't even hurt you i said good
and then he took the shell and threw it
into the the the commode the toilet and
back off the kitchen there and tried to
flush it it stopped up the toilet gave
him a problem that he had to deal with
um then he took the gun then out and put
it under the counter where where it
remained well betty
was terrified she she
kept this to herself because she knew
lloyd she'd believe lloyd killed martin
luther king
she didn't know he'd taken the gun from
the shooter she thought he had actually
done it so she kept
this to herself all those years afraid
and once she said he did send someone to
try to kill her but it was more likely
was just going to intimidate her not
than not to kill her so
it's taken a long time for much of this
evidence to come out
uh after the television trial there
appeared in the memphis commercial
appeal an article long article by a
writer
named steve tompkins um steve had spent
a year and a half researching the
infiltration surveillance and monitoring
of
black
civil rights
leaders and black community activists
and black community leaders
he spent
a year and a half
investigating the infiltration and the
monitoring of
these leaders uh by
army intelligence
and he came to learn that this this was
a pro there was a program of
surveillance of
uh of particularly black uh leaders
uh after the second and second end of
the second decade of the 20th century
because of the fear
of that the russian revolution
um was going to come to american soil
and its prime recruiting
uh
warriors might well be discontented
black
minority citizens so they kept them the
leaders under surveillance for a long
time so the quantum pro in the
in the 60s 50s and 60s is something
that's not
not
unusual has historical precedent
in the course of that whole article
which dealt then with with modern
surveillance of king and
the wiretapping and all of that was
movements there was a tiny little
paragraph
that said and in memphis tennessee on
the 4th of april 1968
there was an an alpha 184
team a six-man alpha 184 team
and he said and no one has ever
explained what that team was doing there
so i went to see steve and this was the
first time i'd ever heard of any
possible involvement of of uh
anyone other than the mafia
in terms of the killing of king
so i went to see steve
and i asked him to help me because james
was in prison we were trying to get him
a trial and he refused he said no these
are very bad people the worst 18 months
of my life i don't want anything to do
with it and i just kept going back to
him and kept being bit persistent
finally said yes okay
i will
uh
i'll help you
and then for quite a period of time
the the arrangement was i would give him
questions he knew nothing about the
assassination the details of it i'd give
him questions and he would go
to two of his contacts were members of
that team
give them the questions they agreed they
would answer them and he would bring
them back and we we went on this route
they would never meet with me because i
was james's lawyer
and
they lived in mexico
they had fled in the 70s because they
thought a cleanup operation was on so
steve
made these trips all the time
and
a picture started to emerge which
indicated that there was an official
involvement although
the killing was in fact a a mafia
contract killing that there was an
official involvement there was
coordination
and there were two photographers
on the
roof of the fire station
which was diagonally across the street
from the
lorraine who photographed everything
so we now learned that there are
photographs of the assassination of
martin king including a photograph of
the assassin
and we made again through steve contact
with both photographers one lives in
costa rica
and um
eventually
when a goat tried to negotiate the
acquisition of those photographs and
eventually they broke down
because at one point uh there was a
security breach
and steve was followed on a to a
critical meeting
and uh by two
fbi agents of a local field office in
miami
and they
one of them stuck a long lens out the
passenger side of the car
and just spooked the
photographer who took off and that ended
those negotiations
we we did file a freedom of information
act suit or colleagues of mine did and
it was denied that the photographs ever
existed
so
the this kind of evidence began to pile
up
and in 1995 i published where we were in
terms of the the state of the
information at that point in time
and in in a book called orders to kill
this work act of state is
the end of the story in terms of of
the assassination of martin king so far
as we are concerned
in
1999
we tried a civil case against lloyd
jowers and other conspirators known and
unknown
you've probably never heard of that
trial either
that trial
took place
because the king family decided
around 96 after
uh carefully considering it and being
somewhat aware of my work over the years
that it was time to try to get a trial
for james alright because he was he was
dying of liver disease
and so the king family came out in favor
of a trial for james and there was a
fair amount of publicity about that so
people probably know that
um
and um that failed because james died
we could have kept him alive i had
negotiated a liver transplant position
for him at the university of pittsburgh
and um
i'm putting an application to the court
to allow him to be
transferred transported to the
university of pittsburgh where the
operation would take place he qualified
he had all he met all of their criteria
and we offered to pay all the expenses
of course
and uh we were denied permission
he was denied the liver transplant that
he needed to live
so
he died in 1998 and i guess we figured
well this is the end of the road isn't
it what are we
what do we do now and i met with the
family and
at length and um
i said there is they said we have any
options there's only one option and that
is we could sue lloyd jowers we have
enough evidence to get a lawsuit going
against him and to bring him to court
and sue him on uh
on a civil case wrongful wrongful death
charge
so
we did that we filed it and about a year
after filing in 98 it's a year after
filing
the case came up
and it came up before the judge that we
wanted it to come before a man called
swearingen a black judge
one of the few independent judges in
that judicial system who was going to
retire
shortly in fact this became his last
case
so judge swearingen heard the case
we started
to try it on a
november 10th i guess it was we tried
this case for 30 days
70 witnesses proceeded to that uh
to testify under oath
70 witnesses over 30 days and it took a
jury
59 minutes
to find for the king family against
lloyd jowers and other conspirators
known and unknown and the whole
all of the evidence gathered finally
under oath
is
uh on the website of the king's center
the kingcenter.com 4 000 pages of
testimony
and so there is that historical record
which doesn't do james any good
but at least it laid out the the whole
scenario of the case and it and it dealt
with all of the nuances all of the
evidence which is uh i can i'm maybe too
much to go into
uh here but we can talk i can answer
questions if you want but it included
evidence of two eyewitnesses who saw
james ray driving away from the scene 20
minutes before the killing as he always
had said he'd done
evidence about the weapon which was not
the throw down gun which was not the
weapon evan it's about the existence of
raoul raul exists he's alive and well
uh and um
four different independent
identifications of raoul from a
photograph that a a
inside intelligence agent uh
kindly provided quietly to me
um
and
this was a photograph
that james earl ray saw in 1978 and
identified
in 1978 and there were two newspaper
articles that said james already has
identified he's finally after seeing
hundreds has identified a photograph
of the man he claims controlled him raul
well
on the back of that photograph was a
name
this had been sent anonymously
anonymously to james and there was a
name on the back of the photograph and
the name was the name of someone else so
obviously this in 78 was the time of the
select committee hearings the
congressional hearings what they hoped
would happen was james would see this
photo goes yes that's raul and then look
on the bottom and this is his real name
and then have a press conference and
announce that and of course then they'd
blow him out of the water and his
credibility would be gone but he didn't
do that he didn't take the name he just
said this is the photograph and so i
showed it to him
when i showed it to him in 95
96
he said yes that's the same one that
identified then this is raul
english merchant seamen identified him
as being in the same bar up in montreal
where james said he always said he met
him
so
one after another his own daughter when
confronted at the door with the
photograph
said well anybody could get that
photograph of my father so she
identified the photograph as that of her
father glenda grabo identified this as
the man who raped her
not only that she called him on the
telephone and spoke with him
for nine minutes
and we talked about old times so
he's alive and well but when he knew we
were on to him all of a sudden
government agents appeared at his house
and a portuguese reporter who
interviewed his wife was amazed to find
her saying this has been hell for us but
you know the government of the united
states has
been so kind and so good they send these
people and tell us how to answer
questions they might they top our phones
they they've done such wonderful things
now this is a retired assembly line
automobile worker
right and why would he
why would the government be doing all
these things for this man right so i
mean
the the evidence mounts and goes on and
on and it's um
the case is is pretty clear the facts
are pretty clear at this point
memphis police department officers are
involved were pretty clear
it's also pretty clear that no one wants
to prosecute and has ever wanted to
prosecute and that the official story
has been defended by publicists forever
and the attorney general of the united
states did a report following the trial
which again confirmed the uh the
official story
the family wanted a truth and
reconciliation commission uh clint
president clinton uh turned it over to
his attorney general and the story has
maintained itself
ever since
but i think um
for me one of the most important aspects
of this book uh orders to kill is not
the solution to the murder of martin
luther king and who killed him
it's one the lessons that we can draw
from this type of government activity
against a man who became intolerable
and he was intolerable
not only because he opposed the war in
vietnam but more
because he was going to bring a half
million of the most wretched of our
citizens to washington to camp there to
live there in a tent city and go every
day up the hill to see their congressmen
and their representatives and try to get
put back into the budget social programs
which have been taken out
and they were going to go up and come
back and go up and come back and the
the
the
forces the security law enforcement
intelligence forces in the in in
imposition in government were convinced
that martin king would lose control of
that group
that they would become so angry as they
became
uh
rebuffed
that they would become violent and they
would become a revolutionary force
and they didn't have enough troops to
put down that revolution westmoreland
wanted 200 000 they couldn't give them
to him they didn't have the troops they
couldn't do it
so
martin king was never going to be
allowed
to go to memphis
from memphis to washington he was he was
going to finish there
his room was changed from a lower
courtyard room to about exposed balcony
room
um
he was well and truly uh set up at
virtually no security at all didn't
think about that in those days
his rooms were monitored and wired in
the hotel as one on either side of him
he was a sitting duck and
the story that came back from these two
officers
was that they were briefed at camp
shelby mississippi
at 4 30 in the morning of april 4th they
were shown two photographs one of martin
king and one of andrew young
and these were the two targets that the
snipers and their spotters had in their
crosshairs
at the time
the shot came from the bushes
each one thought the other did it when
they found out it was some what they
call wacko civilian later on they were
they were non-plus they didn't know what
what had uh what had happened they were
really only a backup operation there
next morning early the bushes were cut
down deputy
uh public works director testified under
oath yeah i was called i was asked to
send a team in there to help the police
and it was a crime scene
so i knew sanitized it
said yeah well they just told us what to
do our people just cut down all the
bushes and cleaned it so no there were
no traces of anything anymore
uh
so
well and truly covered up has been this
assassination but it's important for
americans to understand
that
and not only americans because this
happens this happens throughout the
history and throughout the world but
this is our country this is our time and
it's important to understand that these
things have happened and do continue to
happen and and will continue to happen
uh perhaps unless there is an aware
citizenry to do something about it the
second most important aspect of
of this work in my view
is is a chapter that deals with the
roots of martin luther king because when
you when you understand where he came
from
and the kind of person he was you also
understand
what a great loss
this has been
a loss that has been irreplaceable for
all of these years and how he is missed
and his real mentor historically
was not gandhi
gandhi was his tactical mentor in terms
of non-violence
but his real mentor was john ruskin
victorian british political economist
who
was so committed
uh
to the redistribution of wealth and the
provision of economic assistance to the
the least well-off in any society
that he waged
campaigns and
everywhere he could in england even
though he was known as the greatest art
art
historian and art critic of his day
ruskin had this enormous
feeling for the poor and what had to be
done for humane in a humane society how
they could not be neglected martin's
roots go back to ruskin and if we were
we can take him further back
even into classical times he believed
that
you know we should take this
neighborhood that we have built uh
technologically and now electronically
and we should make it into a brotherhood
but he didn't see us going that way
he saw us using
uh he quoted thoreau off he saw us using
unimproved means
improved means to reach unimproved ends
and
he was horrified at the evil of war
racism
and injustice
and would not compromise lost great sums
of money in uh because of this
commitment
the
the motto that i chosen for the seminar
i convened at oxford university is
non-nova solemn not desumas which is a
uh
latin phrase which says we exist not for
ourselves alone
one of martin's favorite poets was john
dunn
who
wrote that famous poem no man is an
island and the least
uh the least of any person on earth who
is harmed or hurt is a harm
injury to myself that was the philosophy
of martin king
and um
he lived it to the end
and he was committed
to the end to accomplishing those goals
and
he died in the process
okay thank you
[Applause]
i'm glad to answer any questions that
you have
yes
um i was talking with a crime writer a
detective writer he said that he was
tracing out james earl ray's brothers
um and he thought there'd be some
evidence or something there did you ever
talk with the brothers or know much
about that that story
i know the brothers of course um
well i don't know john no one i mean
john is a very uh erratic chap uh so i
don't i don't know he's been out of the
picture so i don't really know him
because i've known jerry ray for almost
all of the time yes
and jerry was always very supportive of
his brother
and very loving toward james and did
everything he could to help him but
jerry um
knew very little when james escaped from
prison
he made his way to canada he wasn't
interested in staying in the united
states at all he was trying to get out
of north america and that's where he was
in montreal when he met raul who talked
him into working for him part-time
but jerry was
i believe kept
very very largely in the dark of these
things
yeah yes
well it sort of smacks the kennedy
a little bit doesn't it but anyway uh my
question is what did
what did uh uh james joe ray
think or what it yeah
he i'm sure had some ideas about who
actually did kill martin luther king and
and
i would be curious to find out what
and who you think actually did it who
who dropped the dime
and got the mafia involved i know the
government uses the mafia in many many
circumstances
do you have any thoughts about i'm sure
you did yeah well there are a couple of
there are a couple of questions there
absolutely um
well
um
james
in in that kind of situation the
situation which he was james would know
only what he
needed to know in order to do what he
had to do
and so as a result he was told very
little he remember he was an escaped
convict on the run
and he was in a position where he could
ask questions this guy was feeding him
money keeping him going bought him a car
so
he would be told what he was needed what
he needed to know
nothing nothing like that and and he was
he was moved around and he did things
okay so that
uh and i'm sure that happens in many
many instances right
um
with respect to um
dropping the dime as you put it or who
killed martin luther king
when the decision was taken to kill king
um in my view the coordination was put
in the hands of a little-known uh
military intelligence group
that is housed in the bowels of the
pentagon
and that group uh under its under its
kernel
organized effectively a task force
operation
that group was also involved in a joint
venture with the marcelo organization
the guns were stolen
that were sold were stolen from our
military bases and arsenals and forts
they were trucked into marcelo's
organization come around to be taken off
at houston the the prophets as i was
told were so were split 50 50. so there
was a joint venture relationship between
them
but more than that james ilray's alias
was not an alias it was an identity he
was given an actual identity
of a man called eric galt eric galt
had high national security clearance in
the united states
he was the warehouseman
at a union carbide's plant
in canada outside of toronto
the this military intelligence group and
the pentagon was working with him on
various operations at the this very time
james was given this man's identity why
would he be given this man's identity
well you can only surmise that and
probably because if he was ever stopped
and james is clumsy
and he made mistakes that's how he ended
up in prison
uh he was often too late for a robbery
he was going to
pull
i mean that the safe would be locked and
they say
there's a time lock on the same james
we'll give you our money
james said i want your money i want that
no the safe is locked this happened
he ended up being late he was clumsy
only carried five bullets in his pistol
he once he admitted to me with
embarrassment that he kept the firing
pin chamber empty because he shot
himself in the foot once
so he said i cannot do that if there's
no bullet in there you know and so uh
when the prosecutor at the television
trial said to him what would you do you
say you couldn't kill anybody you've
never killed anybody i said no i used to
shoot squirrels when i was a kid with my
father's 22. oh you couldn't kill
anybody what would you do if you came
into my store and you pointed a gun at
me and i pulled a gunfight and i pointed
my gun at you
what would you do you wouldn't shoot me
he said
i'd say let's make a deal
this is the nature of this of this guy
so
he was very much uh given that identity
so if he was ever stopped
when they ran a check on him he would
they would be told to let him let him go
well i did i've not gotten into any
investigation of any other
assassinations i had my hands full with
this one and a man in prison yes can we
hear some of the details of the denial
of the liver transplant
well it was it was unprecedented
it had never been done
uh he didn't have a right under law
the commissioner of the department of
corrections did not have the statutory
authority to allow it to happen i mean
there's a whole range of a whole range
of specious reasons that
that they used
um just like they took judge joe brown
off the case on the eve he was about to
grant us a trial
they took joe brown off and did it
without allowing oral argument before
the court of appeal
in tennessee they took him off just in
the night that decision was made yes
there's been speculation over the years
what do you think about that
yes the fbi's role in the
killing of martin luther king was in my
view to cover it up
and their role was the was the cover-up
they took control of the investigation
and basically uh perpetuated the
cover-up
mr hoover sent one of his personal
agents best agents as a liaison
to senior military officer
in the intelligence wing and that man
kept going back and forth and back and
forth he effectively seconded this man
and um
he knew everything that was going on
he was not involved in the on the ground
details and the organization of those
details at all in my view but he then
controlled the the investigation
no i don't think it started with hoover
but i think he concurred and i think he
believed from the outset that the only
way that martin king could be
dealt with effectively
was to be killed and he said that
more than once
to a friend of his hl hunt an oil man
and i had witnesses who used to
hunt's administrative assistant
um
used to be present at a number of those
those meetings between hoover
and hunt and hunt used to have a private
line phone in his desk just just to
hoover and hoover gave hunt is his
director of security so they were very
close and hunt used to think we can stop
king
by my lifeline programs he had a program
that used to broadcast
and hoover would give him scurrilous
material and hunt would put it out on
the air you know and and so hunt thought
this was going to do it hoover said
that's not going to do it
we got to take other other steps let me
just go to something else yes
about this
and all that you've realized about the
state of mind of our government where
has that left you personally
philosophically and what lessons have
you learned
well it's um
i've learned to be
i've learned to be cynical
and skeptical
uh i'm a first generation american
my parents uh emigrated here from
ireland and i grew up as uh as a as a
kid believing everything that one is
taught
in school the american dream
yeah the american dream type of thing
my life was a little different in that
when i was 12 i was a baseball player i
mean i played baseball
at columbia and i was i was a ball
player and basketball and baseball and
then but when i was 12 i loved that game
so much that i wanted to play all summer
and i lived in the middle class
neighborhood and the kids wouldn't play
so anyway i could play was i take my
brown sandwich bag and i go into across
town on trolley car in the ghetto
and i i would play there all day with
with black kids so i had an advantage
that a lot of white middle class kids
didn't have because i began to see how
people lived
and i began to wonder why they lived
like this
you know i remember seeing herbie throw
his shoe at a rat that ran across the
living room floor and i never seen a rat
in a living room before you know so i i
the whole that was so i had i had i
regard that as an advantage
not only for my skills as a as a ball
player but for my growth as a as a human
being so i think you have to
become when you go through these kinds
of experience you have to become
skeptical
and uh you have to question everything
and have no illusions about
power
and i am
i now am um
very unhappy to see the course
that this uh
empire is taking because it is an
empirical force no question about it
and i see a lot of the same remember
rome was a republic first
and it's
went into
uh
empirical room and so we see a lot of
the same a lot of the same so i think
citizens have to be alert they have to
more than anything you have to teach
your children
teach your children
teach your children to question because
long after we're all gone
we know we must have them teach their
children and this otherwise this oral
tradition will will be useless yes
how do you feel about today's
political leaders representing the
legacy of uh
martin luther king
political i'm sorry i didn't how do you
feel about today's leaders
representing the legacy of martin king
well it's politically
opportunistic isn't it i mean it's
it's useful for them to do it
anyone who can ride on the legacy
bandwagon or martin king
uh is going to do it
uh people who hated him and disdained
for him when he was alive civil rights
leaders you know walked away from him
when he was alive he called me very late
at night after riverside speech and said
you know they're all gone now
they've all told me not to do this all
my brothers my friends are telling me
that so we got to build this new
team because they're all gone this is
not the thing to do to attack this this
government
so
you know i i almost became ill one time
when we we were arguing at a parole
hearing for james and the prosecutor
district attorney general attended and
he went on about how much
this nation had lost when martin king
was killed
you know and i knew the man's roots
and uh
but that's what politicians and
political figures do isn't it
and so we have to learn to understand
yes
as a close friend of um dr king uh what
do you think if he was around today his
involvement if any would be with the
current anti-war movement
against the war in iraq and what do you
expect
that he'd say to us as citizens what our
duty should be as americans well i don't
have any doubt if he were around today
he would be um very much
active in the leadership against uh the
iraqi adventure
and he would work in every way he
possibly could you know to um
to stop that war or to prevent it from
happening or to preempt it or
discontinue it once it started because
he would know
um
what the results will be and we all
should know what the results will be
we're going to once again witness the
slaughter of thousands upon thousands of
innocents
before there is ever any military
engagement
there will be an engagement of our
military with the civilians
of the of iraq
once more an ancient an ancient
civilization irrespective of its
leadership and ancient civilization and
peoples what we're talking about here
you know the sumerians the ancient
civilization of samaria 6 000 years ago
had its roots in the in the southern
part of iraq
babylon is iraq
so
we're about to destroy not only a people
live warm breathing human beings
of tender ages mostly
who are the most vulnerable
but we're
going to remake and restructure an
ancient civilization's
symbols
and heritage
yes
yes
was the freedom of information act any
help at all to you when you were
investigating the case and when you were
writing your books
no
when it comes to the question was that
if you heard the question the question
was does the freedom of information act
any help when we were doing research and
the answer was no freedom of information
act can be used
in a number of matters
and
it is possible to use it but when it
comes to very very sensitive cases and
issues like this it's not it's not uh
useful as far as i'm i'm concerned
yes
i think um
from
from john kennedy to paul wellstone we
all sort of know on a gut level
who and what is behind all this
do you think it'll ever reach a critical
mass to the point where
it all comes out and and
you know there's really an investigation
and the people who are behind it are
really
taken to task punished for it
not absent a revolution
you know mr jefferson said you need a
revolution every 20 years
you know and when jack kennedy held a
meeting in the white house of all the
nobel prize winners they had had them
all for dinner one night
he toasted them and he welcomed and he
said uh ladies and gentlemen never
before have so many brilliant minds uh
gathered at this table to dine except
when mr jefferson dined alone
jefferson with all of uh the
imperfections that we we all carry
um
believed that you had to cleanse
uh a government and agents and people in
power
uh every 20 years however you have to do
that well of course
we have not
done that there's no sign that we're
going to do that power has consolidated
to a a point in the united states today
where its primary behavioral
characteristic is arrogance
and frankly those are the seeds of
destruction of any political system when
it gets to that point in time in my
lifetime the media the control of the
media has become so consolidated
that it is uh
um
it's not it's not just frightening it's
it's something to lament because there
isn't a possibility of getting
free and active debate you know in this
this issue
um yes
when you were a journalist in vietnam
you mentioned
the photo
the photographs were taken that was the
most televised
war in history there were two things
that helped the anti-war movement it was
the most televised war in history you
have that classic picture of the little
vietnamese girl naked running that's
been napalm and all the body bags coming
back yeah yet during the persian gulf
war and afterwards with almost a half
million iraqi children dying after we
blew up their infrastructure and almost
no body bags coming back and our press
have never shown us pictures of the
decimation of baghdad
how do we we rally against a war with no
body bags and no televised destruction
of the civilian population what i find
very interesting is that throughout the
world today there is building
a movement an anti-war movement of
surprising strength with surprising
speed
and um
and it's almost happening from the roots
uh of of the soils of the of of people
who
who know instinctively now what this is
all about
um it's very difficult to engender this
kind of feeling in the united states
when the
the the drum beats get louder and louder
continually throughout the day
you know
and it's a very difficult task to
overcome when you don't have independent
any independent media when a
transnational corporations control them
uh bottom lines are important to them
you know my first book was to have been
published by harper collins and they
wanted a chapter removed at the end of
the day everything was clear they wanted
one chapter removed and and uh
it would have made the killing of king
just a mafia killing so i couldn't do
that
well
some people still think it might have
been better to do it and then come back
with it later but i don't think so it
was too integrated the forces were too
integrated
yes lady back there
were you asking a question
oh okay yes
in your opinion did he know this was
coming how worried was he for his
security i'm sorry can you speak a
little um in your opinion how worried
was martin king for his security and how
much do you think he knew that he was at
risk and that this might happen to him
well i mean he
you're asking how prepared he was or how
to
assassinate he expected he would be
killed he did
a lot years before the
years before he was almost killed many
years before when he was doing a book
signing in in harlem and a woman stabbed
him and the and it just by a
fraction
um missed
an artery that would have killed he
would have died so he but he believed he
would be killed didn't know when it
would come
but he believed he would he would be
killed
precautions
not enough
not enough
didn't take precautions uh about being
killed didn't take precautions about the
wiretapping that was done all the time
because he said look i don't mind if
they know what they hear what we're
saying we're not doing anything illegal
let them hear and what we look at that
now we say
wow glorious naivete that is because
of course you're not doing anything
illegal but they unders they learn your
strategy your movements they everything
about you this is the enemy you're
dealing with here
right well okay i don't know how much
time they're telling me i don't have too
much time huh two more right yes
yes um i think after the assassination
of jfk he told coretta that he was going
to be killed he always knew he was going
to be killed somewhere along the line
but it seemed almost as if he had a
special knowledge at that time he was
planning a treat at kissimmee with
thomas merton many things he was
exhausted depressed but i think he knew
towards the end that this was going to
happen well i think the assassination of
malcolm uh
moved him more
i think uh that so that was i think a
very sobering event for him
okay one more question is there anyone
who hasn't asked a question all right
yeah
all right well let's yeah with you
you talked about the the military unit
in the pentagon where did all that
started was this an autonomous unit
somebody had to make the decisions and
for the the orders to go
well what have you learned about that
all right try to understand this
in 1967 a hundred cities burned
this country
uh
in autumn of 67
the pentagon was put under siege
there are 200 000
people
at the at the pentagon
putting it literally under siege
um
someone told me that
they had a friend who was one of the and
was one of the military aides
and he was up on the on the um uh
powerpivot of the pentagon at on the day
of the demonstration and there was
mcnamara
and the chairman of the joint chiefs no
the chairman of joint chiefs wasn't
there mcnamara was there the chief of
staff was there
assistant chief of staff for
intelligence was there
and down the line
uh came the question starting with
mcnamara
what do we do about this
they were terrified these were
barbarians at the gates
and the
chief of staff shook his head and said
i don't know
bill what do we do about this
and he said
bill said
just give me the go-ahead and i'll take
care of this problem
and um
i believe
that there was a consensus
that martin king had to go i
i believe the president of the united
states did not know the details of it
but i would be very surprised if he
didn't know that it was going to happen
because on the 31st of march he
announced four days before the killing
that he was not going to run again
so i i would have thought i would have
thought this was well known and i would
thought today that there's not much
doubt
that um
people in the know in this country
understand what it is that's being
covered up
and why it's being covered up and
particularly now it'll be covered up
more than ever because now more than
ever
government
lacking credibility
for another war
needs all the credibility that it can
get
okay
okay
thank you for coming
if anyone is interested in the book an
act of state we do have it please feel
free to come in and ask any more
questions we'll be right in this room
you can come this way that way whichever
way you like and the book is in the
front thanks a lot
william pepper is author of an act of
state the execution of martin luther
king
it's published by verso on the web at
versobooks.com
[Music]